so here i'd like to talk about what the
gradient means in the context of the
graph of a function so in the last video
i defined the gradient
but let me just take a function here and
the one that i have graphed is x squared
plus y squared f of x y equals x squared
plus y squared so two dimensional input
which we think about as being kind of
the x y plane and then a one dimensional
output that's just the height of the
graph above that plane
and i defined in the last video the
gradient
to be a certain operator an operator
just means you're taking a function and
you output another function and we use
this upside down triangle
so it gives you another function that's
also of x and y but this time it has a
vector valued output
and the two components of its output
are the partial derivatives
partial of f with respect to x
and the partial of f
with respect to y
so for a function like this we actually
evaluated it
let's take a look um
the very the first one is uh taking the
derivative with respect to x so it looks
at x and says you look like a variable
to me i'm going to take your derivative
your 2x
to x
but the y component just looks like a
constant as far as the partial x is
concerned and the derivative of a
constant is 0.
but when you take the partial derivative
with respect to y things reverse it
looks at the x component and says you
look like a constant your derivative is
0 but it looks at the y component and
says ah you look like a variable your
derivative is 2y
so this ultimate function that we get
the gradient which takes in a
two-variable input xy some point on this
plane but outputs a vector can nicely be
visualized with a vector field and i
have another video on vector fields if
you're feeling unsure but i want you to
just take it take a moment pause if you
need to
and guess or try to think about
what vector field this will look like
i'm going to show you in a moment but
what's it going to look like the one
that takes in xy and outputs 2x 2y
all right have you done it have you
thought about what it's going to look
like
here's what we get
it's a bunch of vectors pointing away
from the origin
and the basic reason for that is that if
you have any given input point and say
it's got coordinates x y
then the vector that that input point
represents would you know if it went
from the origin here that's what that
vector looks like but the output is two
times that vector so when we attach that
output to the original point you get
something that's two times that original
vector but pointing in the same
direction which is away from the origin
i kind of drew it poorly here
and of course when we draw vector fields
we don't usually draw them to scale
you scale them down just so that things
don't look as cluttered that's why
everything here they all look the same
length but color indicates length so you
should think of these red guys as being
really long the blue ones as being
really short
so what does this have to do with the
graph of the function
there's actually a really cool
interpretation so imagine that you are
just walking along this graph you know
you're a hiker and this is a mountain
and you picture yourself at annual point
on this graph let's say what color
should i use
let's say you're sitting at a point like
this
and you say what direction should i walk
to increase my altitude the fastest you
want to get uphill as quickly as
possible and from that point you might
walk
you know what looks like straight up
there you certainly wouldn't go around
in this way you wouldn't go down so you
might go straight up there
and if you project your point down onto
the input space
so it's this is the point above which
you are
that vector the one that's going to get
you
going uphill the fastest the direction
you should walk
for this graph it should kind of make
sense is directly away from the origin
because here i'll erase this because
once i start moving things that won't
stick
if you look at things from the very
bottom
any point that you are on the mountain
on the graph here and you
when you want to increase the fastest
you should just go directly away from
the origin because that's when it's the
steepest and all of these vectors are
also pointing directly away from the
origin so people will say the gradient
points in the direction of steepest
ascent that might even be worth writing
down
direction of steepest descent
and let's just see what that looks like
in the context of another example so
i'll pull up another graph here
pull up another graph and its vector
field so this graph it's all negative
values it's all below the x y plane and
it's got these two different peaks
and i've also drawn the gradient field
which is the word for the vector field
representing the gradient on top
and you'll notice near the peak
all of the
all of the vectors are pointing kind of
in the uphill direction sort of telling
you to go towards that peak in some way
and you know as you get a feel around
you can see here this very top one like
the point that it's stemming from
corresponds with something just a little
bit shy of the peak there
and everybody's telling you to go uphill
each vector is telling you which way to
walk to increase the altitude on the
graph the fastest it's the direction of
steepest descent
and that's what the direction means but
what is the length mean
well if you take a look take a look at
these red vectors here so red means that
they should be considered very very long
and the graph itself
the point they correspond to on the
graph is just way off screen for us
because this graph gets really steep and
really negative very fast so the points
these correspond to have really really
steep slopes whereas these blue ones
over here you know it's kind of a
relatively shallow slope by the time you
get into the peak things start leveling
off
so the length of the gradient vector
actually tells you the steepness of that
direction of steepest descent but one
thing i want to point out here
it doesn't really make sense immediately
looking at it why just throwing the
partial derivatives into a vector is
going to give you this direction of
steepest descent
ultimately it will we're going to talk
through that and i hope to make that
connection pretty clear but unless
you're some kind of intuitive genius i
don't i don't think that connection is
at all obvious at first
but you will see it in due time it's
going to require something called the
directional derivative
see you next video